what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and things are about to
ramp up big time for marvel studios and
the mcu right now we're actually on a
little bit of a break the disney plus
miss marvel series just ended last week
and now we have about a month until the
next one starts which of course is she
hulk so we have a tiny little viewing
break right now but as far as news is
concerned we definitely do not have a
break as sdcc is this weekend and we're
expecting some pretty big reveals from
marvel studios and according to a new
report it looks like we actually know
all of the disney plus shows that are
going to be coming out in 2023 which
means we now pretty much know the entire
mcu slate for 2023 and right now we're
only a little over halfway done with
2022 and have plenty of marvel projects
coming up this year still plus not to
mention the new announcements marvel
studios is going to have for us this
weekend at hall h at san diego comic con
marvel has a lot in store for us in the
upcoming years and now we're in an mcu
where mutants exist kamala khan has made
history as the first official mutant of
the marvel cinematic universe in our
main universe the 616 universe yes
marvel studios did introduce the
fantastic four and the mutants in doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
but it was in the other 838 earth
universe and i'm sure all of the events
that took place in multiverse of madness
will have repercussions but for right
now kamala khan is the only mutant
inside of the mcu that has been
announced of course we assume that there
are other mutants out there the only
question is who is going to be revealed
next and how long until we get the
official x-men team in the mcu and also
the fantastic four the fantastic four
were teased all the way back in san
diego comic con of 2019 so hopefully
this year kevin feige and marvel studios
have some great answers for us and great
updates but like i said we pretty much
know what is coming in 2023 so let's
talk about this recent report now first
things first if you're not aware of all
the projects that are going to be coming
out this year let me briefly go over
them of course thor love and thunder is
in theaters right now and as far as
movies are concerned we have black
panther 2 wakanda forever coming out
november 11th of this year and that does
it for movies but as far as marvel
disney plush shows are concerned we
actually have a lot coming out between
now and the end of the year we have
she-hulk which is coming next month we
have the i am groot series we have what
if season two and then we have werewolf
by night which hasn't officially been
announced by marvel studios yet so that
should be an announcement at sdcc this
weekend and then to top it all off we
have the guardians of the galaxy holiday
special at the end of the year so still
a lot coming this year but let's talk
next year what can we expect from marvel
studios well as far as movies are
concerned we actually know three of the
movies that are going to be coming out
next year but i'm assuming that there
are actually going to be four movies
coming out next year not only three but
the three movies that we know of so far
are ant-man and the wasp quantomania
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and the
marvels which is captain marvel 2. a
pretty great lineup so far now here's
the thing with the future of the mcu
right now marvel studios has already
announced all of phase 4. phase 4 should
end with thor love and thunder unless
marvel is planning on switching that up
but since they announced that phase 4
does end with thor 11 thunder when they
revealed the entire face for slate we
could safely assume that all of these
other disney plus shows that they have
announced are actually a part of phase
five and with all of the movies and the
shows coming up that they've announced
they actually have content all the way
through phase six already it's just a
matter of what marvel studios really
wants to tell us and keep in mind marvel
studios always has an order shows and
movies have to connect with other shows
and movies that's the great thing about
the mcu it is a cinematic universe it is
all connected even though some people
say that it doesn't really feel like
that right now but keep in mind we are
in a building phase and things are
starting to come together and kevin
feige even said we really are going to
start to see things come together and
connect and see where the mcu was going
so where is it going in 2023 well
according to a report from tvline.com
they have listed five mcu disney plus
shows that will be airing in 2023 and
keep in mind and they say this as well
this is not limited to only five as it
stands right now 2022 is going to have
at least seven disney plus shows
released or i should say disney plus
content because some content like the
guardians of the galaxy holiday special
is just going to be one release not an
entire disney plus show but a special
event that is going to last around 40
minutes so 2023 is not limited to these
five tv shows but they are as we know
according to this report the first one
being secret invasion now of course we
knew that this one is coming and this is
going to be a very very big one it's
definitely going to involve the scroll
the cree and who knows after what we saw
in miss marvel it could even involve
some mutants but secret invasion is
supposed to have some very heavy hitting
story plots that are really going to
affect the mcu as we know it so this is
a big one next we have the iron heart
series now this makes sense for this
show to come out in 2023 because we know
that iron heart is going to be in black
panther wakanda forever black panther 2
will give us the introduction of riri
williams this will give us a tiny bit of
her backstory and then she will go on to
have her own show the iron heart show
and this might also connect to armor
wars as well especially if marvel sticks
true to the comics of how riri williams
gets her iron heart armor because what
we know about armor wars is that it's
going to be about how iron man's
technology gets into the wrong hands now
of course riri williams would be the
right hands but you can see how easily
that would connect now the next one that
we all know is loki season 2 and this is
where things are going to go down
ant-man and the wasp quantomania is
going to introduce a true king to
conquer and maybe even a few more
variants of gang but loki season 2 is
where we really dive into who exactly is
kang the conqueror who exactly is this
new big bad and all of his different
variants that are fighting each other
threatening the entire multiverse with a
multiversal war and personally right now
loki is still my favorite disney plush
show so i'm super pumped for season two
then we have the echo series and some
weren't expecting this to come out so
soon however the story does pick up from
hawkeye and some fans might not be too
excited about this show but if all of
the rumors end up being true it actually
is going to be pretty awesome we're
going to have kingpin return and
daredevil is going to make his mcu debut
actually in his suit not just matt
murdock being a lawyer for somebody
which we saw in no way home and will
most likely again see in she-hulk but
full daredevil fighting and according to
some rumors we could even see jessica
jones appear and or quake which i know
people have been really wanting to see
for a very long time so the echo series
does have the potential to be really
really awesome and then according to
this report agatha house of harkness is
going to be coming next year as well now
i'm super excited for this series i
loved agatha in one division and i'm
hoping that one agatha harkness is just
going to be great on its own but two
hopefully it actually leads up to a solo
scarlet witch film this has been
reported many many times by many
different insiders and accounts and it
kind of seems like it's all but
confirmed right now so i would
definitely love to get more of a
backstory about agatha harkness the
darkhold maybe even c'thon and dare i
say mephisto although we won't count on
that but it will be really cool to see
kind of the history of magic since she
is a true witch and kind of taught wanda
about witchcraft so if these are the
shows coming in 2023 that's a really
great lineup and of course keep in mind
that they can always put other shows in
there as well like armor wars or the
untitled wakanda series that we're going
to be getting but as far as our 2023
disney plus lineup goes it's pretty dang
good so far so be sure to let me know
what you think about it in the comments
down below and be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel news don't forget to give the
video a like and for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof